-For people who are skittish
like, how is this --
how does this film --
What do you recommend for that
-Well, I had a fun experienc
with my best friend, Goldie,
who I took to the premiere
And at first,
she didn't want to go.
At first, she was like,
"I can't.
It's too scary.
I can't see it."
And I just guilt-tripped her
-Yeah.
-And I was like,
"No, that's totally cool.
I worked really,
really hard on this
and poured
my heart and soul into it.
And I went to Australia,
and shot for 2 1/2 months.
And I hurt my neck."
-Yeah.
-"And I busted my ass.
But that's totally cool."
-"I had to do a harness stun
five times, which is a lot."
-"Which is a lot, by the way
It may not sound like it."
-"I know that some people,
some dummies think it's normal."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, some dummies.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"But that's cool.
You can't sit through the movi
for an hour and a half?
That's totally fine."
And so I got her to go.
So she sat next to me,
which I promised her I would do.
And then we had, like, a syste
where she would hold my arm,
and then I would sort of
tap her.
So if there was something
scary coming, I'd go...
-Oh, that's very nice.
-Yeah, very nice.
Except I totally messed it up.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-So I'd be watching.
And I'd just
be watching the movie.
And then I'd just sort of
tap her arm
just, like, lovingly, you know
[ Laughter ]
And then she'd be like,
"What are you doing?"
And I'd be like,
"Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
I was just -- I love you."
[ Laughter ]
And then, there was one scene --
there's one scene
in the movie --
Well, there's a lot of scenes --
scary scenes in the movie,
but there's one scene
where something really bad
happens at the end.
And I was like,
"Something kind of scary
happens at the end of this."
And she was like, "Okay."
And then I proceeded to tell her
about the other actor
in the scene
and how great they were
and how wonderful.
We should have dinner with them,
and they're so funny,
and she was gonna love them.
And then something bad happene
in the scene.
[ Laughter ]
And she literally
pulled her arm away
in actual anger and was like
"You're a dick."
[ Laughter ]
And, like,
refused to speak to me.
-So you were basically like,
"You will love them.
We should have dinner.
Oh, right.
Dinner's not a possibility."
[ Laughter ]
-So I kind of messed that up
But we had a system,
but, oh, well.
-I know that
you were doing a junket,
what people do when you do
press, you and your co-star.
And there was an effort made
to scare you guys during that.
And junkets are not,
by nature, scary.
-No. Not at all.
Only by length.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah, they tried to scare us.
They pulled us into a room
And we bought it,
hook, line, and sinker.
We were such stupid actors
-Yeah.
-You know, and they were like,
"Our stunt coordinator, Harry,
who's from Australia,
has flown out to interview you."
Which is not a thing.
-Right.
-No one's going to do that
-Yeah.
-And so we we're like,
"Oh, cool, right.
Of course he did,"
because we're actors.
So, like, of course,
everyone wants to talk to us
[ Laughter ]
-Right, that's all you hav
to do to trick an actor
is be like,
"People find you interesting."
It's like, "Oh!"
-"Of course they do!"
-Well, well, well.
-"What can I do for you?"
[ Laughter ]
We started -- We sat down
and started taking picture
of each other,
like, just, stupid.
And then they started
to really, really scare us
And they had this whole
magic thing that they did.
And they did all the trick
in the movie.
And we actually legitimately
got really scared.
And there's a great video of i
which I posted on my Instagram
And I immediately did the tota
anti-feminist thing and, like,
threw myself into his arms
[ Laughter ]
And was like,
"Oh, my God, I'm so scared."
I, like, lost a shoe.
Like, I was not the superher
that I am in this movie at all
I was a total --
-Yeah, the minute --
Yeah, I want to make it clear,
I would do that, as well.
[ Laughter ]
I scare easy and jump fast
-You would.
-I will jump into the arms o
a stranger if it comes to that
And then you --
we were talking backstage here
you're about to leave to start
shooting season four
of "Handmaid's."
-Yeah, yeah, we start on Monday.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And, I mean, so exciting.
I mean, one, I just want to ask,
like, when you embarked on this,
I think, you know,
anytime you embark on this -
which at a time, you know,
for Hulu, there weren't
a lot of shows that they had had
that resonated
like this with people.
Are you just shocked
that you're still doing it
You must be so happy.
-I am.
I am, really happy.
-Yeah.
-It's a real -- It's --
I'm very grateful for it.
And I love doing the show, so...
-I know you can't say much
Things weren't going great for
June at the end of season three.
-All that running.
-Yeah, so much running.
[ Laughter ]
I just remember --
All I remember is, you wer
very winded at the end.
-Yes, the whole --
I can tell you this --
the whole first episode
is just me out of breath.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Just me trying
to catch my breath.
-No dialogue.
It's just a lot of, like..
[ Breathing heavily ]
Holding up one finger.
-The resistance, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I got this.
-What is --
Can you say anything about it?
-I think we're gonna lean into
the comedy of the show.
-Yeah, I think it's about time
-Yeah, I think we're
really gonna -- yeah.
-'Cause I will say -- and
don't want to be critical of it.
Very few laughs
in the first three seasons
-And we've taken that note
We understand that.
And we're gonna
lean into the comedy of it
You know, pump up
the romance a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
You know, like "This Is Us."
-Yeah, yeah,
a little more "This Is Us.
-A little more "This Is Us."
Yeah.
-It's interesting, though,
'cause when Bradley Whitford
was here, I remember talking
to him about the fact that
actually, on set,
it's not the most
depressing place in the world.
Like, you have a lovely crew
And I imagine, like, when you're
dealing with subject matte
like that, you can't, like
bring it to set
and bring it home every nigh
over the course of
however many months
you're doing it.
-You can't. You can't.
Also, because there's like
a hundred crew members tha
don't really care, you know?
[ Laughter ]
They don't care about your drama
and your resistance
and just want to go home
to their families.
-But that must make it easier.
It must make it easier to, like,
leave it on the set,
which makes you have a healthier
life, I would imagine.
-Yes, absolutely.
It definitely, definitely does
We have a lot of --
believe it or not,
we have a lot of fun
making the show.
[ Laughter ]
Isn't that crazy?
-I know it's a weird thing
to say, but I can't, like --
the opposite would be
so much worse, obviously.
-I know, it would be terrible.
-Yeah.
Because I feel like that's wha
we're missing is, like,
we would love to see
the blooper reel
from "Handmaid's," I feel.
[ Laughter ]
Just with a lot
of terrible sound effects,
like, "Wah wah!"
[ Laughter ]
-Just me panting.
The whole time.
-Congratulations on the film
I can't wait to see the next
season of "Handmaid's Tale."
It's always such a delight
to have you here.
-Give it up for
Elisabeth Moss, everybody.